[Música]
[Aplausos]
como desenvolver resiliência diante de
um projeto de vida
quando ele está prestes a dar errado o
soltado lino sou biólogo jornalista e
mais dez anos eu venho fazendo
reportagens sobre viagens principalmente
sobre ecoturismo turismo de aventura e
turismo de base comunitária
e foi nesse último tipo de turismo que
eu descobri que o turismo ele pode ser
uma ferramenta muito importante de
preservação tanto ambiental quanto
cultural
eu sou o márcio sanches eu sou
publicitário fotógrafo e sempre gostei
muito de viagens e sempre tentei ali ao
meu trabalho com o que eu mais gostava
que era viajar
viajei por toda a américa latina e numa
dessas viagens agente um confortável a
gente percebeu que a gente um objetivo
de vida muito comum que era trabalhar
viajando
foi aí que a gente decidiu fazer uma
grande expedição pelo interior do país e
fazer uma expedição desse porte que se
propõe a dar uma volta em todo o brasil
demanda muito planejamento e no decorrer
desses três anos que a gente planejou
essa viagem a gente se deparou com
alguns dilemas e o primeiro dos dilemas
era qual seria o nosso meio de
transporte
a gente poderia ir desde ônibus
carregando tudo nas mochilas até com o
carro do ano ea gente não teve a menor
dúvida de que a gente queria com o carro
do ano a gente fez essa viagem com o
carro do ano de 1976 uma chevrolet
carvão que foi comprada pelo preço de 5
mil reais o preço uma bicicleta
praticamente mais 15 mil reais mas
adaptamos é ela inteira
transformamos em uma casa com uma
cozinha que nos permitiu passar até sete
dias em autonomia sem precisar
reabastecimento
a gente poderia dormir nessa nesse carro
e trabalhar nele ele tinha mesa luzes de
led tomada tudo pra gente realmente é
dever dentro do carro e por ser uma
experiência uma expedição independente a
gente não tinha
o dinheiro é fato a gente gastou com a
reforma do carro a gente gastou com o
restante dos equipamentos audiovisuais
que também eram precários mas que a
gente precisava para concluir o nosso
objetivo e não sobraram 12 mil reais
isso era 50% do que a gente imaginava
gastar na viagem
foi aí que a gente batizou essa
expedição de expedição raiz expedição
raiz por dois motivos o primeiro é que a
gente foi atrás das raízes culturais do
país
e o segundo por que a gente faria com 12
mil reais no melhor estilo roots
então a gente não tinha todo o dinheiro
e sabendo disso a gente levou para essa
viagem 500 fotos da nossa carreira já
impressas e essas fotos seriam o
complemento de renda pra gente conseguir
terminar essa expedição bom eo
planejamento tão grande ele precisa ser
muito detalhado também nas rotas que a
gente pretendia fazer o nosso objetivo
era produzir uma série para tv em 12
episódios e feito isso nós planejamos
cada um dos indícios que nós passaremos
e de uma forma que pudesse a abranger o
maior número de paisagens diferentes no
prédio do país eo maior número de
culturas que o nosso país também tem
então um belo dia 8 de outubro de 2014
a gente saiu daqui de são carlos e damos
início a expedição raiz
o primeiro disse não foram as cavernas
do vale do ribeira ainda que dentro de
são paulo maior conjunto de cavernas uma
concentração de cavernas do mundo sendo
do vale do ribeira a gente seguiu até o
ponto mais ao sul da viagem no rio
grande do sul para conhecer os cânions e
aparados da serra ea cultura gaúcha
aí então a gente começou a subir o mapa
em direção ao centro o s
primeiro por pantanal depois na chapada
dos veadeiros lógico pequenos problemas
sempre aconteceu um dia estava um vidro
do carro no outro dia precisava trocar o
limpador de para-brisa e pequenos
problemas sempre acontece a gente estava
preparado para isso
então a gente entrou na região norte do
brasil até o tocantins e o nosso
objetivo era conhecer já button
hoje ela continha que está no nosso
nosso roteiro não só pelas paisagens que
cada dia são mais conhecidas as dunas
douradas os fervedouros mas pela cultura
que existe dentro da comunidade mumbuca
é uma comunidade quilombola matriarcal e
que é conhecida no mundo inteiro pelo
trabalho que eles fazem com capim
dourado é como voltar falou a gente não
podia deixar o japão de fora e isso a
gente um problema muito grande quer
entrar no japão
para quem não conhece o jalapão dos
lugares que têm a menor densidade
demográfica do brasil - de um habitante
por quilômetro quadrado
isso sei que para talvez a densidade
demográfica da amazônia e outro problema
que tem no japão são as estradas
todo mundo que vai pro japão aconselha a
não entrar com um carro que não seja 1
mas a gente tinha uma missão a gente
tinha que chegar até esse clube de multa
essa comunidade de mumbuca e lá fomos
nós
e aí foi um fatídico dia em uma dessas
areias estradas de areia que a gente
colidiu o nosso carro
sim a gente bateu o nosso carro numa
pedra é a batida foi tão grande que na
hora a gente não conseguiu abrir as
portas a gente teve que sair pelas
janelas do carro a gente abrir o capô um
motor estava tombado dentro do carro
todo óleo espalhado pelo chão e foi
nesse momento que a gente viu nosso
projeto de vida indo por água abaixo
a gente chegou no fundo do poço para
consertar o carro a gente não sabe nem
por onde começar
essa é a verdade seria preciso
praticamente remontar a estrutura do
carro em um lugar em uma cidade com 4
mil habitantes contando a zona rural
extremamente longe de qualquer outra
cidade e nesse momento a gente cogitou
desistir do nosso sonho e se não fosse a
ajuda do wando o mecânico que nos
acolheu talvez a gente nunca tivesse
conseguido realizar essa expedição até o
fim
ele que morava na oficina mecânica
garantiu pra gente que fome e lugar para
dormir a gente não teria problema então
ele emprestou um quartinho
oficina mecânica gente apelidou este
quartinho carinhosamente de cativeiro e
foi lá que a gente passou 30 dias 30 um
longuíssimo os dias esperando o momento
do nosso carro está pronto para sair e
foi só essa tranquilidade que o wando
nos passou diz que sim era possível
resolver o carro e ele não sabia se ia
terminar expedição mas a gente sairia do
jalapão ea partir desse momento de
tranqüilidade que ele nos passou a gente
começou a fazer o que a gente chama de
uma faculdade de resiliência
nesse momento a gente precisa ter
tranqüilidade para desenvolver cinco
habilidades que eram essenciais para a
gente seguir adiante
bom a resiliência ela é um conceito que
passa por várias áreas do conhecimento
eu sou biólogo e na biologia por exemplo
resiliência é a capacidade de um
ecossistema de uma área voltar ao seu
estado original se regenerar depois de
sofrer uma devastação na física
resiliência capacidade que um corpo tem
de voltar ao seu estado original depois
sofreu uma deformação e na psicologia ou
na vida a resiliência é a capacidade do
ser humano através ao passar por uma
situação de problema e sair desse
problema de preferência melhor do que
ele entrou e como foi sair desse
problema a gente ficou com 3 reais no
bolso com o nosso carro quebrado ao
ponto da gente tem que vender a gasolina
do tanque para comprar comida ea gente
só conseguiu ter o autocontrole para
continuar pensando e replanejando a
expedição raiz pelo nosso mentor que
garantiu wando era tão bagaceira como
ele mesmo dizia que ele morava ele tinha
apenas uma cama ele não tinha nem fogão
nem geladeira e no dia que o acidente
aconteceu ea gente decidiu morar na
oficina mecânica ovando comprou uma
geladeira e um fogão abrigou a gente da
oficina e garantiu que fome a gente não
passaria e pelo tempo que a gente
precisar se a gente ficaria na oficina e
foi com essa tranquilidade que a gente
conseguiu conversar e depois de longos
30 dias
morando numa oficina de lapão a gente
conseguiu sair de lá é bom sair do
jalapão agente enfrentaria um outro
problema o nosso cronograma já estava
tudo atrasado ea gente deveria
atravessar a região do alto xingu com o
nosso carro é bom a região do alto xingu
é completamente desabitada e na estação
das chuvas fica completamente alagada
o nosso carro estava destruído então a
gente teve que adequar nossa rota nos
adaptar pra seguir em frente com nosso
plano nosso plano era conhecer a
amazônia ea gente não poderia fazer um
retrato do brasil que não mostrasse
amazônia então por conta disso a gente
subiu até belém pará com o carro
deixamos o carro em belém pará
pegamos todo o nosso equipamento tripé
hd de computador câmera lente medo se
troca de roupa
usamos tudo nas nossas mochilas
cargueiras algo que não estava previsto
e começamos a fazer um mochilão dentro
da expedição foram 45 dias navegando
pelos rios da amazônia
muitas vezes comendo uma maçã queijo
durante dias e somente assim nos
adequando a gente conseguiu manter a
nossa proposta original dos doze
discípulos é o que a gente tem que
desenvolver também durante esses lugares
foi muita humildade não que a gente não
tenha sido ou não tivesse sido humilde
no começo da viagem mas até então a
nossa moeda de troca ainda era o
dinheiro as relações ainda se baseavam
no dinheiro
depois da amazônia gente já não tinha
mais dinheiro ea gente percebeu que as
nossas relações tinham que mudar o nosso
próximo destino era um dos lençóis
maranhenses
todo mundo aqui deve conhecer porque os
lençóis maranhenses é um dos destinos
mais famosos do brasil mas a gente não
queria retratar só os lençóis
maranhenses a gente queria retratar as
comunidades que vivem nos oásis dentro
do parque nacional
só que são comunidades que ainda vivem
sem luz elétrica ainda sobrevivem de
forma da pesca artesanal de forma bem
movimentado
são pessoas que não estão acostumadas
com um relacionamento turístico é e foi
aí que a gente teve que desenvolver a
humildade e despertar empatia dessas
pessoas
a gente precisava chegar até esses
lugares se aceito primeiro depois
explicar o nosso projeto
causar empatia e consegui esse contato é
e só dessa forma a gente conseguiu
realizar e registrar fielmente essas
comunidades
nessa nessas fotos que vocês vêem aí a
gente teve que ficar dois dias dormindo
na cabana dos pescadores até eles terem
a confiança de vir falar com a gente
então isso mostrou pra gente que a nossa
moeda de troca na estrada passava a ser
outro bom sair das eleições embora esse
agente teria não só que chegar até aqui
de volta mas teria que atravessar o
nordeste inteiro até chegar no nosso
próximo destino que era o sertão da
paraíba cariri e o nosso carro vazava
óleo compulsivamente se a problemas
elétricos
é o nosso equipamento audiovisual já
estava bastante cansado as lentes
começando a fundar pra você ter uma
idéia a gente não tinha uma foto de cap
ado a gente não se hd de backup
a gente simplesmente tinha confiança de
que a gente chegaria até o fim
independência ter um equipamento bom ou
não a gente seguir o nosso planejamento
fazia tudo o que era previsto e tinha
claro nossa cabeça que a gente chegaria
aqui em são carlos de volta nem que
tivesse que empurra o carro e foi o que
aconteceu do maranhão até recife
toda vez que a gente precisava ligar o
carro ele só pegava no tranco então
ficava um volante um é lá pra trás
empurrava um carro de duas toneladas e
meia mas a gente tinha confiança que
assim ou seja como fosse a gente
chegaria até o fim
é mas só confiança numa hora dessa eu
acho que não era suficiente então foi
realmente conhecendo essas comunidades
vivendo das maneiras mais isoladas
possível possíveis que a gente reafirmou
o nosso propósito essa viagem só foi
possível porque a gente tinha um
propósito muito maior do que a viagem se
a gente desde o planejamento sempre
afirmou entre a gente que a nossa idéia
não era mostrar o nosso feito não era
mostrar uma viagem de carro mas sim da
voz para essas comunidades que vivem de
maneira isolada e que fazem do turismo
de base comunitária uma nova saída para
a entrada de dinheiro para movimentação
econômica e para a preservação da
cultura
pura e dos ambientes que eles vivem é
essa família do do sertão do cariri
a gente não conhecia a gente nunca teve
nenhum contato com eles ea partir do
momento que a gente chegou a gente foi
acolhido como os como filhos e tivermos
literalmente casa comida e roupa lavada
durante uma semana
a avó não não fazia não deixava a gente
sai da mesa sem a gente comer e antes
dos cinco pratos de cuscuz
então a gente veio de uma fase muito
ruim da expedição de repente a gente
estava fazendo cinco refeições por dia
né e essas coisas só fizeram a gente
reafirmar que tudo o que a gente estava
fazendo tinha um propósito maior e no
fim nessa viagem
a gente começou a perceber que é não era
mais um projeto meu e do março esse
projeto ele é um projeto de todos todos
aqueles que passaram pelo nosso caminho
antes durante e depois da viagem mas
principalmente durante a viagem
cada porta que se abre para a gente cada
sorriso de acolhimento que a gente
recebia cada prato de comida cada abraço
cada entrevista sincera que a gente
fazia a gente percebia que eram aquelas
pessoas que estavam fazendo a expedição
raiz não a gente então a gente percebeu
que existe uma gratidão imensa eterno
infinita por cada uma dessas pessoas que
passou por nós ea expedição raiz é fruto
principalmente delas nós somos meros
agentes vetores que fizeram possível mas
o projeto é dessas pessoas
e foi assim depois de 240 dias na
estrada depois de percorrer mais de 24
mil quilômetros e de passar por 18
estados do brasil e manter os mesmos 12
destinos que nós planejamos gastando 25
mil reais durante toda a expedição que a
gente concluiu a nossa viagem e uma vez
que a gente chegou e começou a tratar a
60 mil fotos que a gente trouxe os 12
terabytes de vídeo que a gente trouxe e
começou a divulgar nossa história a
gente começou a virar notícia nas
principais mídias do país telejornais
revistas muito conhecidas e sites
todo mundo começou a contar a nossa
história e é o nosso objetivo era contar
nossa história para o maior número de
pessoas possível
a gente pede
um documentário né sobre turismo de base
comunitária de 30 minutos
esse documentário foi selecionado em
oito importantes festivais ensino
gráficos de turismo pelo mundo e isso
deu muita notoriedade ao nosso projeto
isso deu muita visibilidade para a gente
conseguir nosso objetivo final que era
colocar a expedição raiz na tv
e esse ano a expedição raízes estreou na
tv em 12 episódios e realmente com a
essência a gente está mostrando o
trabalho sobre o turismo comunitário a
vida dessas pessoas e dando o
protagonismo aos verdadeiros raízes do
brasil e como a gente falava no carro
durante a viagem
ainda é só o começo então agora o nosso
plano é fazer as expedições raízes ao
redor do mundo eo nosso próximo objetivo
é rumo às raízes indígenas da américa
latina
só que não mais 22 a família cresceu
minha esposa e meus dois filhos irão com
a gente mas vai com uma moto acompanhado
a gente esse é o nosso próximo objetivo
ir atrás das raízes indígenas da nossa
américa latina
muito obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]